well as violence continues between
israel and palestine in the middle east
some here in las vegas are working to
bring attention to that issue
so they're holding an event tonight at
sunset park it's all happening
live local now let's check in with sasha
loftis
denise there are more and more people
coming to be a part of this convoy
part of this event starting at sunset
park and is set to go
up the strip now they are supposed to
leave here for this convoy in about 15
minutes we're told
this is all related to the latest
conflict between israel and the
palestinian militant group hamas
this violence flared up again earlier
this month but has really been taking
place
on and off for about 25 years now those
here today are taking a stand to support
israel in that conflict this is one of
several events
this group has held in the last few
weeks here in las vegas
and they hope the size of this protest
tonight will bring attention to the
issue
here locally we're told about 500 people
could participate tonight we have
around at least 100 here so far today
and again they're heading up the strip
starting here at sunset park
now we will be here monitoring the
situation heading along with them
through this protest along the strip
we've already spoken to a couple people
out here today who shared their
views on this issue make sure to stay
with eight news now both on air
and online as this particular event
continues this convoy continues
for the latest stay with us reporting
live tonight sasha loftis
8 news now